hey everybody welcome back to the
stronger by science podcast as always my
name is eric helms and i am your one and
only permanent host of the show uh
however today i have the unique pleasure
of being joined by someone you might
have heard of he's done some writing in
the fitness industry a temporary guest
host greg knuckles greg thanks for
joining me
thanks for having me on how's it going
i'm well i'm pretty good you know it's
it's been a long time hosting this
podcast
and uh i feel like i need a little bit
of a change of pace it's great to have
you alongside of me uh it feels it feels
different today i don't know what it is
but it also feels good
well i i definitely appreciate your
magnanimity uh for having me on
well i i appreciate that use of a big
word that i don't know what it means and
i'll pretend to just uh appreciate it
and know what it means
so
all right folks so so first off i just
want to say thank you for listening to
the stronger by science podcast and and
if you want to do a little more than
listen if you want to support us there
are some ways to do that
so first off
probably our largest profit margins come
from
the sbs
pod code that you can use at bulk
supplements and not only is that the way
you can help us the most that's also
your personal path to wealth uh if you
think about the kind of savings you'd
make on that
it's it's right up there with with rich
dad poor dad you know that that that
truly transformed most people's personal
finances uh back in the early 2000s and
this is no different it's the next
coming
uh in addition you can also subscribe to
mass that's monthly applications and
strength sports we go into the details
on a monthly basis um
of the most recent research on strength
and physique sports i am one of the
authors as well as greg just uh
interesting little crossover with him
being the guest host today but we've
also got some folks you might have heard
of dr mike zurdos and dr eric trexler is
that his name greg
i think so i think so too honestly he's
been added recently we're not 100 sure
on that and he's i'd say he's doing okay
and we'll probably keep him on for the
long term additionally we also have a
fantastic diet tracking app that's
called fit genie
and if you want to check out which wait
or are you sure
sorry i'm sorry my uh you know it's
weird that i spelled it wrong sorry
macro factor i actually don't even know
where i got fifth genie from that that
is a really common typo to make yeah you
know so most people have the qwerty
keyboard i have one that literally has
transposed just the letters from macro
factor with fitching
so and that's crazy yeah you know
you think apple does a good job with
with most things and then they just give
you a wacky keyboard and here we are so
apologies for that folks
definitely want to check out macro
factor
which is a an excellent diet app for
anyone who's looking to uh modify their
nutrition and used a data-driven
approach to personalize it and make sure
that uh you know the the the assumptions
you're making are at least grounded in
something factual uh there might be
better better you know
diet tracking apps out there i don't
know and uh
but but i've heard good i mean if there
are i'm certainly not aware of any yeah
yeah honestly it would be nice if i had
some type of uh genie that i could ask i
can just rub the lamp be like hey my
first wish is can you tell me about
other diet tracking apps that might help
me get fit genie and i would ask them
and then that genie would recommend to
you uh macro factor maybe maybe what
we'd have to see about that um
but moving on another another great way
to support us and really help yourself
would be through our our coaching
platform so we have stronger buy science
coaching we've got a lot of great
coaches who have a lot of expertise
however greg i don't know if you've
heard about this uh long time good
upstanding company 3d muscle journey
that also has some coaching specifically
for natural bodybuilding
uh no no i have not and uh in fact i'm
i'm not interested in learning more
about them so let's proceed that's all
right that's okay just uh the word on
the street greg is that they're pretty
good and since i am the actual host i'm
just gonna leave it at that and you can
choose on your own who you'd like to
hire for whatever your goals might be
just being aware that there's a lot of
good options out there for many
different things
with that said uh greg how's the road to
the stage doing
you know
road to the stage is
not going the best right now uh oh man
maybe you might seek out some coaching
from from some specialist who helped
people get to the stage
no it's weird um
so a particular level of calorie intake
that was having me reliably lose weight
for a couple weeks uh now just for
whatever reason for the last week or so
uh the scale's ticking up honestly i
think it might just be allergies uh
dear viewers you'll see me rubbing my
face a lot all throughout this episode
uh pollen time has definitely come to
north carolina and my head certainly
feels like a balloon um
just just inflating with mucus
and who knows maybe that's a generalized
thing throughout my entire body so
anyway uh it's it's been a rough couple
of weeks for road to the stage but
overall trajectory is still positive and
i
i feel quite confident that things will
get back on track
i'm glad to hear it and uh
is your weight up is it up or just kind
of maintaining
it's up like a pound and a half okay not
too bad
so i think if anything
it's impressive that you have a pound
and a half of snot in your head right
now
i'll tell you what man it feels like i
have five pounds of snot in my head
right now it's it's terrible like
and the annoying thing is it's so
beautiful like raleigh in the spring is
tremendous and our neighborhood
specifically like everyone is a
gentleman or gentlewoman gardener um
like there there's so many pretty trees
pretty flowers just all over the place
one street over is a rose garden that
you can go walk around and so like i'll
do that and it's nice and then like two
two hours later just i'll i'll feel
uh
you know how your head feels when you
really really grind out like in rpe 14
deadlift like your head feels like it's
gonna pop like uh you know like the hey
what am i is it from animal house like
that's how my head feels um
so yeah i mean it it feels like way more
than a pound and a half of snot but uh
yeah maybe maybe that's all it is
well let's hope so and just for
our non-american listeners five pounds
of snot is about 2.2 kilograms step one
thereabouts
how is the road to athens
you know greg i had one of those i don't
know if this ever happened to you but
but you wake up and you look in the
mirror
and you feel taller
more attractive you realize wait i can
see this in in the mirror and i don't
even need to put on my glasses
and then you're like you know i'm i'm
i'm truly a different possibly better
man today
and you think about
the life choices you've made at this
point
and some of them just do not sit well
with you anymore and they maybe feel
pointless or even counterproductive
so the road athens is cancelled i'm done
with it i don't understand why i even
started it um
running is truly something that i think
degrades
uh the the moral fiber of the soul and
the character
that one tries to build and i've fully
rededicated myself to uh competitive
bodybuilding and strength sport and and
nothing else so
any physical endeavor i have if it
doesn't support the goals of looking
amazing in a speedo
or
potentially looking
uh you know amazing in a singlet while
lifting mediocre weights
then i'm not doing it so so road to
athens sorry folks uh the closest thing
you can get from the road to athens
would be like the road to the natural
olympia which is at least culturally
similar but that's it it's over it's
done greg i'm sorry
no that sounds good for me and just one
thing i'll note for the listeners that
means now within the canon continuity of
the stronger by science cinematic
universe road to the stage is no longer
a road to athens is no longer a segment
uh
it was just declared dead so if it ever
comes up on a future podcast again that
is a major continuity issue and uh
there should be a lot of hate mail
directed at eric which one you'd be you
be the judge
yeah i i would be fine with what
whichever host
is the primary host
named eric when those continuity errors
are made make sure you email them i
probably send two emails because
sometimes the first one goes to spam
but you know the good news greg is now
we can both report on the road to the
stage because
that's we we share that now you know
we're simpatico so if that is if you're
ever back on the podcast
yep we'll uh we'll see
all right so as as i understand it you
have a research
review segment lined up i do but um
if you could let me host my own podcast
a little bit i'd like to hear about some
feats of strength if you have any of
those that you'd like to uh discuss
first
oh yeah totally forgot about that uh
yeah so i i do have one this week which
uh maybe i should have mentioned last
week but uh whatever we didn't do feats
of strength uh in that episode uh
jennifer thompson competed at the arnold
and she hit
a bench press of 145
and a half kilos or about 321 pounds
um
which
would be a new world record if it was a
meet where the the standard weight
classes were adhered to uh but it was
just kind of like an exhibition thing
but the very noteworthy thing about it
is jennifer thompson as i understand it
has been competing for about 70 or 80
years at this point uh and this was uh
her her biggest bench in a meet and i
think her second biggest binge ever i'm
pretty sure there was a video from a
couple years ago of her doing uh 325
touch and go in like a football weight
room uh but you know she's been
competing forever and this is the
biggest bench she's ever hit hit in a
meet um so just uh
another crowning achievement on a career
that has had uh many and you know i'm
sure there are many more to come
yeah no honestly jen thompson is is
i think i think you might have even
posted on this on facebook that if you
were to look at how many standard
deviations she is above other bench
pressers
that it's an outlier performance that
might not be rivaled even across other
sports do you still hold that to be
you know a belief
it depends how wide of a net you cast um
because there are several paralympic
benchers who are putting up comparably
great numbers um but among like usapl
ipf competitors like yeah she's i'm
pretty sure the numbers she's putting up
are
when last i checked like six and a half
standard deviations from the mean uh
which is absolutely wild and i think
like
four standard deviations from the mean
of internationally competitive
female power lifters
yeah and and just to reiterate for those
who who might not have picked up on it
she's not a super heavyweight this is
this is someone who
competes typically in like the uh i
think the 63 kilo class i think at this
comp specifically she was around 65
yeah for the american listeners that's
that's like 144 pounds benching over
three plates it is
mind-boggling and like like greg said um
she's an m1 approaching m2 so
uh
honestly it's yeah she's continually
amazing so it's a big shout out to jen
thompson that's an incredible bench for
us
yes and now greg
i have my my physique science review
which which you could lead me into yeah
i don't know if you want to keep this
job or not no i i already tried and you
rejected my offer so lead yourself in
however you want
well thank you greg for that a previous
offer uh that you led me in perfectly on
to this segment so uh so for those who
don't know
for those who are a little more
interested in the the stronger by
science aspect and and less on the look
amazing by science aspect
bodybuilders do peak
but they do it in a unique way so so if
you're not familiar those who get on
stage for competitive bodybuilding they
follow what's typically called peak week
protocols and unlike peaking for a
strength sport this is not you know
primarily about tapering and you know
increasing intensity and trying to get
the biggest 1rm on the platform or like
you might see in various other sports
where you're trying to be in the best
specific performance place you can be a
marathon runner maintaining their
ability to run marathons while dumping
fatigue
or you know more power-based sports that
are more velocity-dependent trying to
peak that characteristic
this is all about peaking appearance
and it's had some very interesting
theories behind it and traditions if we
want to go back to
the very early stages of physique sport
and how it's progressed over time but
typically what you're going to see and
i'm not necessarily endorsing all these
practices which we'll get to in a moment
but the typical procedures that people
follow for peaking
involve some combination of water
manipulation electrolyte manipulation
and carb loading and the idea behind
this all is that you're trying to
manipulate the intracellular to
extracellular water ratios that you have
more of your body water in muscle to
make your muscles look larger and more
impressive and more separated
and less in the subcutaneous space so
there's less to blur that definition
and
we're leveraging some physiological
principles to do that that are often
related to the sodium potassium pump
and so you'll often see loading
potassium cutting sodium
restricting water to some degree or
various degrees there's a fair amount of
heterogeneity between different
bodybuilders and how they approach that
and then a loading carbohydrate with the
idea that because carbohydrate is stored
with glycogen that'll that that process
will preserve uh the water that is in
muscle so that any water that is lost
comes from other spaces so you look
amazing
now greg i can tell you as a competitive
bodybuilder myself who's probably been
to close to 100 shows at this point and
has competed in double digit myself
and one caveat primarily natural
bodybuilding shows i have been to some
untested shows as a spectator but
as a coach and as an athlete i'm very
kind of siloed in the natural
bodybuilding space
when people follow these these
procedures
at least in the amateur ranks to me as
an observer it seems like they're
basically
rolling the die and even odd they're
gonna
feel like they that improved their
appearance or potentially did nothing or
or actually degraded their appearance
so
um it is definitely something that is
maybe more of an art than a science
generally
however that is not to say that there
isn't a fair amount of research on this
topic and it's actually quite
interesting
so uh so so greg uh i don't know if
you've noticed this when looking at the
literature but there was a period like
in the 80s and 90s where there was a lot
of bodybuilding research that was on
specifically like the nutrition and the
training processes and
interviewing athletes going to
championships you know measuring
you know body composition all that stuff
and then there was a real dearth of
research from like the 2000s until maybe
up to like 2010 or so
not to say if you didn't search pubmed
and bodybuilding you wouldn't find it
but it's all in like eating disorders
and anabolic steroid use
and then boom
starting with that first case study by
rossall
that i think came out in either 2012
2013 of a natural bodybuilder then for
the last 10 years
it's been i guess another little
renaissance
of bodybuilding research i don't know if
you've seen that
so it might not shock you to learn i
have not spent that much time on pubmed
looking for bodybuilding research
um but that that is interesting what
what do you think uh contributed to
those those kind of spikes and walls do
you think that it
had to do with
the
kind of relationship in people's minds
between bodybuilding and steroids and
then just the degree to which uh
steroids fell out of favor um you know
following ben johnson and the mlb
steroid investigations and and all of
that stuff yeah i think it's a
combination of factors and this is
something we still see today the
societal impact on
what research has done
and how much of it's published and the
interest they're definitely not it's not
like you know we often talk about the
ivory tower of research like it's oh
we're separate from society and and
we're doing this research that should
inform everyone else we're not
influenced by the peasants but i i don't
think that's actually the case so i i
think that if you look at the 80s and
90s
they're coming off the high of like the
80s action movie era you know arnold
schwarzenegger's at his peak popularity
um and it's cool to do bodybuilding and
you know we had a lot of fitness
interest in the 80s that was very
bodybuilding influenced and i think
you're seeing the echoes of that in the
research that's actually looking at
competitive bodybuilding
then i totally agree
then we had some of the very public you
know congressional hearings on steroid
use
we had
mark maguire saying he used andro
and there's this general kind of
negative view that that happened in the
late 90s into 2000 that i think
persisted for a while
so that that i agree with you and then i
think
interestingly enough
the majority of the research that's come
out kind of like in our sector since the
2010 you know after that point like the
20 teens onward a lot of it's been on
natural bodybuilding and i do think that
you know folks like lane norton and
other very kind of science focused
folks in that community have they
created another generation of interest
and you know i know a lot of people who
got into grad school and doing research
because they were motivated by that and
i think bodybuilding does draw a lot of
heavily analytical people and i don't
think it's a uh you know a random thing
that that many of them ended up getting
into science so anyway that's my little
armchair
sociology explanation for it i don't
know if you buy it
no i i think that makes sense i i also
wonder if there's
if there are class dynamics in play to
some degree
um
just because like i
i feel like at least um
when when bodybuilding and gym culture
initially really started blowing up in
the 60s through the 80s it was
more egalitarian to like maybe slightly
middle upper middle class
like the sorts of people who would tend
to filter into academia
and then i feel like from the mid 80s
certainly into the 90s uh like the class
associations with exercise started
trending towards more like
um
like lifting
and especially like bodybuilding and
strength sports
being more of like a
middle to lower middle class pursuit and
like cardio being more the type of
things that the folks who would tend to
matriculate into academia like focusing
on
and then
more recently
uh crossfit blowing up in popularity
getting a lot of people who have a lot
of money to spend on box fees into
lifting weights uh maybe getting more
academic types into lifting again like i
wonder if that's if that's also
influencing things to some degree
interesting
yeah and and i wonder how much crossover
there is between
some of the people who are interested in
researching crossfit because i've met a
few crossfit researchers at conferences
and and in the bodybuilding world that's
interesting and uh and yeah i don't know
about you but for me
i've always wanted bodybuilding to be
exclusively for the uber rich just to
know that i'm i'm with my peers
i'm just kidding i couldn't even keep a
straight face um but uh but yeah i i
think that is interesting and it's
that's uh that's that's speculation that
i that i haven't thought of previously
so
anyway i mean i i could be completely
full of [ __ ] that's
j just a thought that came to mind hey
well there's nothing wrong with thoughts
you know you're not making any strong
claims and that's okay but to talk about
some claims how's that for a segway
let's talk about the research and
interestingly enough uh the peak week
research
follows the same pattern so we've got
some research that was done in the 80s
and 90s then there's a big gap
and then we see it start up again more
recently
and i think that's important because
this is not to say that these traditions
and practices haven't changed over time
they have even in just the last uh
geez 15 years that i've been involved in
competitive bodybuilding even just
within the silo of natural bodybuilding
i've seen a pretty stark change in how
often people manipulate water or
electrolytes to the same degree some
some things have held true i don't think
carbohydrate loading practices have
changed that much over time but i think
that's interesting so
first let's kind of talk about how
common this is um and this is not
starting with with research in the 80s
and 90s but uh chappelle and colleagues
did a survey
of primarily uk bodybuilders but it was
recent published in the last three years
if i recall correctly and i think when
you look at bodybuilding in the modern
era you're going to see more ubiquitous
practices at least across the
english-speaking world
because of social media and i think this
is reasonably representative of the
english-speaking bodybuilding world but
anyway this this survey of uk
bodybuilders found that 91
of them manipulated something during
peak week they engaged in in the
quote-unquote peak week practice they
didn't just kind of coast in and leave
things the same
so this is a
incredibly common practice more than 9
out of 10 bodybuilders are are probably
doing this and probably physique
athletes in general so that's to give
someone an idea of the scope of it
and then to talk about like what has
been observed we're going to go back in
time a little bit we'll actually follow
the timeline of this research
and i think
knowing that bodybuilders are doing this
and have been doing this by a long time
for a long time excuse me
we can we can get little hints of what
might be happening so all the way back
in the i think the 80s and 90s there was
a study by bauman and colleagues
and they noticed that in the last 24 to
48 hours
in a group of bodybuilders this is an
observational design
that the bicep thickness increased when
they measured them right before
competition by almost five percent
now
we've talked about uh the the challenges
of contest prep and we've talked about
how much it typically results in in
muscle loss and it's a challenge to
maintain glycogen while you're also
trying to lose there's body fat so it's
it's unlikely that there's just this
random spurt and muscle growth in the
last you know days before competition uh
and knowing if you look at the research
that these bodybuilders were probably
engaging in some type of carbohydrate
loading it gives us a hint here
that something they're doing is quote
unquote rescuing performance if you will
but again this is just an observational
study
interestingly enough not too long after
that we have literally the only
experimental data on carbohydrate
loading which is only one aspect of peak
weeks and that was done by ballen and
colleagues and this was really cool when
i found this i remember during my
master's greg i was going through all of
the research on bodybuilders because my
master's was specifically on
manipulating
macronutrient intake while dieting
and i thought this was pretty relevant
and i found this study and i was like
wow i had never seen this before but it
is while i really appreciate that it
exists i do think it highlights the
uniqueness of some of these strategies
in the state of of extreme leanness and
having been dieted for for weeks if not
months at a time
so ballen attempted to replicate a
carbohydrate load but they did a couple
of things
that that maybe
preclude us from having strong
confidence in their findings being
generalizable to bodybuilding so first
off this did not bury the lead uh they
didn't observe an increase in muscle
girths after carbohydrate loading and
and their conclusion was hey therefore
you know carb loading doesn't do
anything for muscle size
however uh the the athletes they had
were lifters not bodybuilders and they
were not preparing for competition so
the body fat percentage of these male
participants was around 10
which is a lot higher than what you'll
see reported than some of these more
recent case studies of between you know
four to six percent for uh for for male
competitive bodybuilders they hadn't
been dieting um and they actually
weren't even in an energy deficit uh all
they did was they had one group shift to
a lower carbohydrate version of the same
calorie intake and then one on a higher
carbohydrate diet
and then saw what happened so
the question is is
do we actually expect someone who is not
lean having not been dieted and not
actively going into an energy deficit to
really see substantial muscle glycogen
losses
and if you look at other research on
carb loading and endurance athletes
and carbohydrate restriction and what is
required to deplete muscle glycogen we
see that muscle glycogen is relatively
stable until you start exercising or if
you're in a really large deficit and the
changes aren't massive so this is like a
week-long study
so i don't think we should have expected
uh just shifting the proportion of
calories in a non-dieted state to
actually have produced the kind of
changes that bodybuilders are after so
unfortunately that's the only truly
experimental data we have on this
um and you know
i think i don't know but i suspect this
study maybe didn't encourage a lot of
additional research to be done uh
because we don't see any other
experimental research and the closest
thing we have well and you said they
just looked at muscle girths right true
indeed
yeah so they're you know maybe they
would have found something if they used
more reliable measures like you know uh
ultrasound
probably wouldn't have access to an mri
for a study like that um or just like
high definition pictures and like pixel
analysis to analyze graininess because
that's
you know that's that's something that uh
people care about uh
you know very
very reliable observation yeah you got
to get measurements of graininess in
there so you know you know you're being
facetious greg but i actually 100 agree
that if we really want to measure quote
unquote performance in an aesthetic
sport
what you really need to do is recruit
bodybuilding judges and then blind them
to what is being done with the
participants and have them actually
score the different groups or the the
bodybuilders in different conditions uh
oh yeah i i was half joking but i i
agree with that wholeheartedly uh if the
sport is visual
then the the measurements themselves
like it needs to be visual analysis it's
like you know if if you're interested in
powerlifting performance like just have
people squat bench deadlift like that's
the sport uh you know have them compete
in the sport and and see how they do
versus like uh you know maybe like an
isometric force output measurement or
something like that but yeah like
uh muscle thicknesses or girths that's
all well and good but ultimately it's
about achieving a look so you know just
just uh blind the judges to the
participants like blur their face out or
something take pics
ask the judges to say like hey which of
these picks looks best like you know
that that seems to make the most sense
to me
greg it makes so much sense that dama
rays and colleagues actually did
something very similar to that uh not a
segway yeah
we're killing it i feel like we've got
simpatico here um yeah so 2019 study
the title is and it tells you right here
carbohydrate loading practices and
bodybuilders effects on muscle thickness
photo silhouette scores mood states and
gastrointestinal symptoms that's a 2019
study and that's exactly what demares
did now importantly
this is what i would classify as a
quasi-experimental study they didn't
actually experimentally change the
bodybuilder's diets and then
you know have these very well
standardized groups but what they did do
was they observed a bunch of
bodybuilders 24 males specifically prior
to getting on stage and then they put
them in classifications based upon
whether or not they practiced carb
loading
so
you know it's hard for me to knock that
design for not being like balance but
you know just a better version of it
because realistically if we want to
do studies on bodybuilders
it's really difficult for on game day or
in in game week if you will
to ask them to let a couple of eggheads
at least that's how they perceive it
go in there and experimentally modify
what might have been working well for
them for years
or that they might have paid a coach to
help them design et cetera so i think to
some degree
we shouldn't have crazy expectations as
far as the perfect study design and i
think quasi experimental is probably
about as good as it's going to get
and i think we should
can you just consider that any time
we're critiquing any of this research
but anyway 24 ml bodybuilders uh they're
they're delineated two groups based upon
whether they loaded carbohydrate or not
and the authors operationally
described this is basically how high
were there carbohydrates
and essentially it was did they go over
you know five five grams per kg of
carbohydrate for multiple days and the
loading group on average was consuming
nine grams per kg of carbohydrate
compared to 5.2 in the non-loading group
so we're looking at almost a twofold
difference in groups in terms of their
carbohydrate consumption
and i think that tells you something
and then like i said they did a really
good job of using the specific criteria
by which performance is measured in
bodybuilding to gauge this so they had
bodybuilding judges
look at photo silhouettes now that is a
slight weakness in that the design was
not to look at you know graininess as
you advise correct which i which i agree
with they weren't actually able to look
at the photos of the competitors
i'm assuming this is because for those
who don't know bodybuilding is a small
sport and the judges judge a lot of
shows so it's quite possible that they'd
be able to identify who the participants
in the study were
um
by actually just seeing their physiques
even if you'd blacked out their faces
there are ways around this for and for
enterprising researchers in the future
you can actually recruit judges from
different regions
you know for example you could you could
do this study out in california
and then send some emails out to
bodybuilding federations or shows that
are conducted on the east coast and
because you know you can send digital
pictures you can get around this and you
could potentially get a little more uh
you know granularity no pun intended uh
for for for the assessments of the
physique but anyway
uh what they found was that the judges
did rate the photo silhouettes as more
muscular or just higher ratings i should
say
in the in the carb loading bodybuilders
as well as they observed an increase in
muscle thickness and triceps brachii
muscle thickness so of both the elbow
flexors so the biceps and the triceps
and the loading group where there was no
significant increase in the non-looting
group so i think this is pretty
interesting
in that like you said compared to ballen
they were just looking at girths now
we're actually looking at ultrasound
changes and muscle thickness and we've
got those photo silhouette scores and
the group loading carbohydrate on both
those metrics and one being arguably the
most specific to the sport
actually seemed to favor that
carbohydrate loading group
i've got a question for you sure um
did they
take measurements of anything other than
biceps triceps like did they look at
lower body at all
let me look that up real quick i think
they did and this is an interesting
observation to where
i think uh
i think there's probably a reason why
sometimes we don't observe acute changes
in lower body um
like like
indices of size in response to peaking
and that's the they're very rarely
pumped up
and that's something and also
bodybuilders typically don't train their
legs in like the last at least five days
or sometimes longer it depends on on how
advent guard they are if you will um but
it's a really common thing especially in
some of the untested ranks that are a
little more traditional in my experience
for carb loading for people to stop
training legs like five or seven days
out and then not pump them up on game
day so it does make you wonder if
they're like progressively losing a
little bit of
of like body water or so i should say
lower body
muscle water over time as they get
closer to the competition because they
don't want to have that blurriness and
typically in traditional bodybuilding
approaches also the leg days are brutal
you know
not that they shouldn't be but if you
train them infrequently say one to two
times a week as most bodybuilders are
typically like to train and very very
hard
and you're also doing cardio you're
going to get edema that can blur the
definition so
i think people err on the side of just
rest your legs because that's going to
be the best improvement in in the visual
quality of them and have separation and
it's not worth you know risking losing
that just to have a slightly larger leg
so that's that's my guess
gotcha the the reason i was asking i i
had a bit of an ulterior motive
um
this is something that i think you and i
have talked about before off mike and
that i know
we have discussed on the podcast
previously
my little pet theory that uh upper body
and like specifically bench press
performance tends to decrease in a
deficit faster than lower body
performance tends to uh my little pet
theory uh
is that upper body glycogen depletes
quicker into a greater extent than lower
body glycogen does um
and so if you know if
uh in these bodybuilders who one would
assume were greatly depleted uh if there
wasn't much of a change in
quadriceps cross-sectional area or
thickness after carb loading that might
suggest that like you know maybe even in
those extreme conditions uh maybe the
upper body was very glycogen depleted
before loading but the lower body wasn't
uh at least not to the same extent
that's that's kind of what i was
thinking uh with with asking that
question
no i think it's a very valid question
and and i
i think that kind of makes sense like
you might even be better at
using other fuels and preserving
glycogen in the lower body because we're
ambulatory and we're constantly moving
um while maybe we're not with the upper
body and so i think there's there's a
lot of reason and i've maybe i'm just
speculating and trying to
to confirm my own observations but this
is definitely something i've noticed
anecdotally is that changes in fullness
in response to temporally when you
trained or when you start dieting seem
more obvious in the upper body even
lower so i don't think you're off
and i did pull up the study to clarify
i don't think this study is is a great
piece of evidence to support what what
what's your what you're thinking uh but
there is some other research we'll talk
about that that might because i think
the only muscle thicknesses they did
with ultrasound were the elbow flexors
and tricep uh damn yeah okay however
however they did do circumferences
everywhere else but there weren't
significant changes um if i recall
correctly that we're different between
groups in in the circumferences
themselves but anyway
principal findings is where they took
these muscle thicknesses they did
observe changes that favored the
carbohydrate loading group as well as
those photo silhouette scores
you know favoring them so anyway i think
the take home here is that carbohydrate
loading probably does make you look
bigger
and the uh i would love to see some
follow-up research of a similar design
where they're able to actually look at
you know high-definition pictures um
because one of the one of the fears
quote-unquote is is i don't know if
you've ever heard this term before greg
spilling over
yeah so for those who aren't aware of
bodybuilding terminology the idea is
that you can only fit so much glycogen
in this and therefore so much water into
a muscle and if you overload
carbohydrates that that water has to go
somewhere and spilling over is when you
carbohydrate low and you're looking
better better better then you start
looking worse because you're losing
definition because you tried to load too
much carbohydrate and either too short
of a time period or just the absolute
amount was more than your body could
store as glycogen at least that is what
people think is happening when they see
that
there's a lot of variables at play here
so it's very difficult to disentangle
what's causing that it's not like the
food you eat doesn't have water content
it's not like the food you eat doesn't
have electrolytes and all these things
could be
creating subtle shifts or that you're
not just stressed out or that maybe you
just need a good pump up uh or maybe you
just need to wait a little bit longer to
look better but
ultimately that that is kind of the
prevailing theory so people tend to be
a little more
individualized with carbohydrate loading
approaches ideally and finding what is
right for the person
and a photo silhouette would not capture
those differences so it's possible that
you know this observation of
the photo silhouettes being improved in
the carbohydrate carbohydrate loading
group um could have also happened with
looking worse if if you know enough of
those participants in that study or in
that group i should say
also quote unquote spilled over which i
think is just an important limitation to
acknowledge
so
moving on we do have some other research
and this is actually going to be coming
out shortly in mass where we discuss it
that actually kind of looks at
whether or not what bodybuilders think
they're doing
is actually accomplished so i mentioned
earlier that some of the underlying
theory between say restricting water
loading potassium cutting sodium and
loading carbohydrates kind of your your
typical big three of bodybuilding peak
week if you will
are to increase the intra to
extracellular water ratio
and there is a study that recently came
out that purported to confirm that this
is indeed uh what happened and that
study is titled uh
changes in intra-cellular water ratio
and bioelectrical parameters from day
before to day of competition in
bodybuilders a pilot study and that is
by nunes at all and it just came out
geez i want to say like last month
so anyway
this is going to be good for those who
really want to dive into it in depth and
mass but to give you a kind of broad
overview of it essentially all they did
was they
they asked a group of bodybuilders
[Music]
on the day prior to the competition when
they were weighing in to
get some some anthropometric
measurements
and also to get a bioelectrical
impedance assessment of not their body
composition but their body water so
total body water and an estimation of
extracellular and intracellular water
content
and they did it again
right before they pumped up and got on
stage the next day on game day and the
principal findings is that they found
the intracellular exterior water ratios
increased in every single competitor
that they analyze so out of 11
bodybuilders all 11 increased this from
day prior to day of uh and they noted
these were the highest ratios that have
been observed in the literature and the
highest individual score for the one
bodybuilder with the highest score out
of the sample of 11 and indeed it was
4.4 standard deviations above anything
the authors had found in the research
so at face value
this study suggests that bodybuilders
know exactly what they're doing
and what they're doing does do
theoretically what they claimed it does
and they increase their intercellular
extracellular water ratio
however
uh one thing i noted initially in uh in
some of the methods was that
you know that the methods here leave a
little bit to be desired
insomuch as
uh
how accurate can these measurements be
when they're not done in lab ideal
conditions so for for those who are not
aware if you want bioelectrical
impedance to be decently reliable you
need to take it at the same time of day
with the same proximity to training as
last time
with the same diet and a similar
hydration status and then you can get
pretty good reliability on these
measurements and that is
not only does that apply to body
composition but it also can apply to
body water
and i left it at that and then our
colleague i think we established his
name was dr eric trexler
he went even more in depth in this and
pointed out some issues
that
even just saying that probably is not
enough and if we actually look at the
type of bioelectrical impedance that was
used which was specifically single
frequency
that actually is probably not sufficient
to distinguish between intra and
extracellular water compartments and
actually it still uses estimation
equations where if you were to use
multi-frequency
bioelectrical impedance or spectroscopy
you have multiple signal frequencies
some which do and don't penetrate the
cell so you can actually
accurately estimate the different
compartments of water and not just total
body water
and then i would say greg and correct me
if i'm wrong even beyond that you
started to look at
the actual findings as they were
reported and you thought that perhaps
there were some mathematical indications
that they reached some kind of ceiling
with their equations so can you tell me
a little about that just to make sure i
don't get it wrong oh yeah so for the
for the post training
uh intracellular to extracellular water
ratios and intracellular to total body
water ratios um
as as eric said from pre to post all of
the subjects saw an increase from
baseline um
but then those ratios just the the post
measurement everyone was very very
clustered near the top like uh all of
those ratios for all of the subjects
were you know within like point one of
each other like super super clustered
versus
a lot more heterogeneity and just a lot
more values spread out at the
the pre-study assessment
uh and so i was thinking like damn
that's way more homogeneity than you
ever see in human measures of anything
um and like
uh eric trexler he's he's the the bia
and body comp expert um so i i just
kicked it over to him i was just like
hey man this seems uh this seems strange
that there's this much clustering
is there some sort of like physiological
constraint on what these ratios could be
that's maybe causing a ceiling effect or
just some like mathematical constraint
based on how these equations work that
would uh bring about a ceiling effect
and so
he went and dug up the citation that the
the prediction equation was based on
that was used in the study
and basically if you just plugged
infinity in for all of the variables uh
that actually went into
uh getting those ratios if you just
plugged infinity in it would uh
give you a value that was basically
identical to
where you saw all of the subjects
getting clumped up um
so
i mean basically i i think whatever they
did
was something that
uh just kind of broke the equation
or like put put people in a state
where
the prediction equations were no longer
representative of what was necessarily
going on physiologically
yeah and i think that's a really just
important point that prediction
equations when you're talking about
single frequency bia assessments of body
water are still being used i think the
prevailing thought is that
bia or bis of any type is
measuring body water to estimate body
composition but when we're talking
specifically about single frequency it
is estimating body water to therefore
even make additional estimations about
body composition
and
i think
the the
i don't want to sound too critical of
the authors because to some degree their
hands were tied here so for example they
noted that the athletes were fasted for
1.5 hours
at least and that was the specific
wording and i was like you know ideally
this is like a 12-hour overnight fast
and no training and you know for the day
prior um but how do you but you can't do
that now all of a sudden it's not an
observational study now you're asking
people to not carb load because they're
typically the reason why it's probably
1.5 hours is they're having carbs every
one to two hours they're carb loading um
and
you're supposed to ask them to be in a
hydrated state well we can't that's
that's the variable we're actually
investigating to see the effects of
right
so
we couldn't have asked the authors
couldn't have asked these bodybuilders
to
maintain
a standardized process because it would
be messing with the actual experimental
question
so to some degree they simply could not
do what they needed to do to improve the
accuracy of these equations
and on top of that though these are
equations and these equations can only
be so accurate and if you were to go
into the text of where these equations
were developed they discussed that even
when you do everything right there is a
potential range of under or
overestimation
for total body water of around 5.6
kilograms
and then between
roughly four kilograms to 3.6 kilograms
for extracellular water and
intracellular water by up to six
kilograms
so those are pretty big estimation
errors uh greg i don't know how much
that that matters for
the reliability of between
sorry within subject comparisons day to
day
but
at the very least there is questionable
validity to this um even if we we do see
similar clusters for the same
individuals in terms of their data
points
and then the final problem is that um
these equations were developed in the
first place because the normal
quote-unquote equations that are used
they don't take into account
the body geometries of athletes
so
and and that's good so i mean this is
great that this equation was used rather
than just whatever standardized
equations might have been used in lieu
of them
but if you look at the
the explanation that the authors had for
why these equations are necessary they
say hey you know athletes have very
different body geometries of the general
public and this is something that
researchers know but don't account for
and it can introduce errors into the
estimations of these body water
compartments you know i i don't know how
many
researchers actually know that before
they decide to use bia i was being nice
like one one assumption that i feel like
more people should be aware of because i
think it's very funny and delightful uh
one of the assumptions is that the human
body is shaped like a cylinder
um
which it's it's not
but uh
that's
that's one of the underlying assumptions
of bia that uh is never met but whatever
we we just roll with it
yeah
yeah i mean
it is true like it is unfortunate that
if you're not an expert in your field
and you're using a research method
your typical researcher standard of will
i use this and will i will i do it a
certain way is has someone else
previously done it and can i set them
you know yeah has someone gotten this
method through review before correct
yeah and as we've discussed on this
podcast review is
i'll just be nice and say an imperfect
process that could be improved upon
and again this is no fault of the
researchers you can't be an expert on
everything um and when other people who
you think are experts are doing it wrong
it's very difficult to know that you two
are therefore doing it wrong but
nonetheless
it's just important that we understand
the limitations of this study so we
don't over extrapolate so anyway if we
think that the general public is
different from the type of athletes who
this equation was developed for which is
like team sport athletes track and field
athletes endurance athletes i think it's
reasonable to assume
that untested bodybuilders
are pretty different from those athletes
in terms of their body geometry
especially
the day of competition when they're in
stage shape
so
i think that's a really big limitation
and i think we need to understand that
there's a huge asterisk next to the
findings of this study
one thing i don't think is unreasonable
to state considering this was within
subject design compared just a day apart
is that perhaps
the directionality at the group level
is accurate and maybe the things that
bodybuilders do are potentially
increasing their intro to extracellular
water ratios
but one thing i can't get on board with
greg is that the authors specifically
advised using baa assessment to gauge
the effectiveness of the peak
and the issue there is that even if we
are seeing you know these changes in the
water ratios that are reflected in the
study how do we know that's actually a
good thing for appearance
because if we go all the way back to
my my theoretical explanation that is
traditionally used for peak weeks the
idea that you want to increase your
intra to extracellular water ratio
it sounds really
logical up front but when you think
about it for more than a few seconds
yeah because muscle cells are the only
cells in the body
uh so yeah yeah it makes sense yeah
that's it right extracellular i don't
want that well let's let's just think
about this
for a second right so
the vascular system is extracellular
and
i've heard the pump is good i've heard
it feels like coming uh from a reliable
source from a document whoa whoa whoa
this this is a christian family values
podcast we don't talk about those sorts
of bodily functions here
you know what and more importantly i
believe that same person
despite
their uh their their historical
relevance to the scene has done a few
things in recent times that make me just
not want to support them like suggesting
that maybe freedom isn't the end all be
all and also i believe they actually
smoke weed on camera so i've gotta i've
gotta walk that back i i apologize to
the listeners thank you
uh no no thank you greg um so more
importantly um
like getting back to the subject at hand
if we were to decrease the extracellular
water compartment that would decrease
theoretically uh the water content of
the vascular system which might impede
your ability to get a pump up per se
also if you think about it you know i
was mentioning earlier how you know
edema and the muscle swelling post
workout can can change appearance it
doesn't always negatively affect
appearance one thing i noticed the day
after i do an upper body workout i just
look more swole and more separated and
i'm presuming that there is some degree
of intramuscular but not necessary not
necessarily intracellular swelling going
on
that might be making me just look a
little more jacked so that's not
necessarily directly relevant to peak
week but it is an example
of where intramuscular and intracellular
should not be seen as synonyms
and the vascular system example is an
example of
how extracellular and subcutaneous
should not be seen as synonyms
so
once you start to wrap your head around
that you can see where there are
instances where this starts to fall
apart um
you know another common finding when you
look at these case studies of
bodybuilders when they look at
cardiovascular metrics is that typically
you will see blood pressure go down and
heart rate drop pretty drastically which
kind of goes hand in hand with you know
reds and over training but
one thing you'll experience when you're
dieting and especially as you get leaner
and leaner is that you might just stand
up and get lightheaded
and you'll maybe try to get your heart
rate on like say an elliptical or
something like that and you'll just get
like error because you're below the
lowest for resting
so
it's difficult to get a pump i can tell
you that you're on low carbohydrates
you're you're parasympathetically
dominant all the time it's it's a
challenge to get a pump and one common
recommendation of cutting sodium i don't
see that helping it you know it's not
like
stock standard that every study where
they manipulate or increase sodium do
you see a measured increase in blood
pressure
but certainly for certain populations
into a slight degree you can see acute
changes
in blood pressure in response to sodium
manipulation
so i don't think it's a good idea to
kind of give that double whammy when
you've already been dieting to then cut
sodium
and i think another mechanistic thing to
consider is that the glute4 transporter
in the gut is a sodium dependent channel
so if you're trying to load
carbohydrates and if you're drastically
cutting sodium and the foods you're
eating are low in sodium you could be
making that carbohydrate loading process
slower you could be exacerbating gi
distress it's very common people who
report cramping or potential bloating
during the carb loading process and i i
don't know
that that carb loading goes well hand in
hand with cutting water and and cutting
sodium and i have seen a number of
competitors who've experienced some
gastrointestinal distress in response to
that not filled out the way they
expected and then struggled to get a
pump
so
again that's all based on the idea of
trying to leverage the sodium potassium
pump but i'm not convinced that we
necessarily want to increase the intra
to extracellular water ratio in all
cases or to a large degree
and we do not have any experimental or
observational data that would suggest
that if you do so there is a
commensurate improvement in appearance
and i think that's the next step so yeah
i mean i'm not even i'm not even sure
you can
influence sodium and potassium levels
across across the the muscle muscle
membrane i mean like that's
that's exquisitely well regulated uh and
i mean if
would you suggest greg that you might
have a bodybuilder have a heart attack
if they were able to do that
i mean it could be a heart attack could
be brain swelling from hyponatremia i
mean like the
the reductions in sodium levels that
lead to hyponatremia
are i mean like really big in a
physiological sense but are like kind of
small in just terms of like a raw
percentage basis like you you don't have
to manipulate uh sodium and potassium
levels across membranes very much before
really bad things start happening um
so yeah i mean even if that
theoretically would enhance appearance i
don't know if you could do so without
killing yourself
like i i i literally don't think that's
possible i don't disagree with you greg
and the reason i brought up that morbid
example of a heart attack is that has
actually happened there's been a number
of uh untested bodybuilders who have
you know had full body cramps or but he
actually even had uh heart failure
presumably due to messing with this
because the heart is of course a muscle
um
and have died because of now for the
record these are not just these aren't
natural bodybuilders like eating more
salt or sorry eating less salt and
eating bananas we're talking about
people who are using prescription
diuretics in combination with everything
else so i i don't think anyone's at risk
of this happening with simple
nutritional manipulations but this has
happened at the ifbb level with some
pretty prominent examples in the last
few decades
and
so maybe bodybuilders can and they
suffer the consequences greg
which is unfortunate for sure
but i think
at the very least to me uh to give
credit to the authors this was a
challenging thing to do and they're
trying to answer an important
mechanistic question about how do
appearance changes come about from the
peak week protocols and at the very
least i'd say perhaps
it is possible that bodybuilders are
changing their intradax cellular water
ratio obviously not to the degree where
they're all dying
um at least in this study
i didn't see a follow-up they could all
be dead but i don't think they are
and i think it would be great to to
follow up this study with with future
research so we can get to the mechanisms
by which
uh bodybuilders are enhancing appearance
if it is even resulting in appearance
enhancement
that makes sense to me um
just as a
as a competitive bodybuilder and a coach
um
what's your just kind of like
gut level assumption like what what do
you personally think works
and to what degree do you think it
affects appearance
fantastic question greg i'm glad you
asked so the uh the things that that i
have seen consistently be effective is
carbohydrate loading um i do sometimes
wonder if we're just correcting
depletion rather than
actually super compensating and filling
out um so
and and actually the dimares study made
me go oh maybe maybe it is more than
that because you know five grams per
kilogram
during peak week is not a low
carbohydrate intake and it is
quite higher than probably what most of
them were dieting on but given that the
uh the nine gram per kg group uh did did
look better and had you know increases
in muscle thickness maybe there is
something to it
so i have seen success with
individualized carbohydrate loading
strategies
this is one of the reasons why i like
refeeds and diet breaks it gives you the
opportunity to play with what is our new
maintenance and how much can we push
carbohydrates up and then you can look
at the time course in response to a
refeed to see when someone looks their
best
and people generally fall in a couple
different categories you see people who
just linearly look better as they have
like let's say they have two refeed days
in a row you know halfway through day
one they're looking a little bit better
you know at night they're looking even
better in the morning a little they're a
little bit worse because they've gone
eight hours of that eating and then they
start to look even better again
throughout the rest of that day and then
the day after they maintain that look
and then the day after that they start
to fade
but you see other people who kind of
look a little softer during that process
like they're they are maybe retaining
additional water but they're also
filling out
and there's kind of a lag and they might
look their best to say the day after the
refeeds
and there's other people who
um maybe weren't that depleted in the
first place or maybe don't need to load
that aggressively and just simply kind
of going toward a maintenance look
better so people who operate on a
spectrum and it's probably relevant so
probably relative to their body mass
their diet and just how depleted they
had to get to get lean so i think an
individualized carbohydrate loading
strategy that is
you know timed in such a way that you
avoid that quote unquote like bad load
look but also hits them at the point
when they're still looking separated
and then i have actually had success and
this is anecdotal so i don't think it
means a whole heck of a lot with
if anything
loading sodium not
like huge but like a gram or two uh in
the final days and day of competition um
as it seems to correct some of those low
blood blood pressure issues and seems to
enhance not in everyone their ability to
get a pump and therefore their
appearance
but i don't try to manipulate
electrolytes much if anything i try to
keep them relatively constant and i'm
loading carbohydrate and i'm roughly
keeping water the same as well
and the big caveat greg is that
i do start to practice this in advance
if someone's on schedule for getting
lean you know let's say they're six to
eight weeks out from their first show
it's a great opportunity to
change the refeed schedule such that it
mimics what you're planning to do for
the the carb load and it should be
informed by by prior refeeds and then
you can tweak and adjust uh leading up
to it and the only thing you really
stand to lose is that if you're
manipulating sodium to some degree if
you're manipulating food choices it can
mess with your weigh-ins a little bit
but hopefully at that point when you're
68 weeks out you're primarily relying on
visual data anyway rather than the scale
yeah
yeah that makes sense to me um another
question i had
is so it it sounds like for the most
part the
research methods that have been used to
look into this before
um
you know range from
not great to pretty good um but like
in your mind what would be
the ideal way to study this uh and i'm
thinking about this both in terms of
practically like just enhancing people's
looks i i think we both agree that some
sort of like an
anonymized photographs would probably be
the play there
um but then i'm i'm also curious like uh
like mechanistically how could you look
into this because something's going on
that's enhancing appearance but maybe
you can push it too far and get
spillovers like what is spillover like
how how would you be able to measure
that so just like
how would you design a study
to figure out what is actually going on
that's a good question i think
i think for one there is actually a
place for more experimental work on this
of an applied nature um
i think you can potentially recruit
people who are
reasonably lean and then die at them
and then
just look at different carbohydrate or
any any strategy and just to see does it
does it result in better outcomes and i
actually like the idea of using
um reasonably lean and reasonably
muscular trained individuals who are not
competitors because then you have no
issue with using local bodybuilding
judges because they won't see them
they won't be aware of who they are
and while it's not a perfect population
match
like you you'd reasonably think that
some of these things should apply to to
someone who's a non-competitor and then
you can
you can you can find a population who's
more open to you know experimental
manipulation of their diet
and training and then you can start to
look at like each individual component
in a more reductionist fashion and does
that result in improvement in appearance
so that's kind of the applied one to
really get at the mechanisms i think
you know one thing i i discussed in the
mass article was that
multi-frequency bia is probably or bis
is probably a better step but it's
probably not sufficient because when i
was doing my again i'm not eric trexler
but digging into the research to my the
best i could tell when i looked at
review papers on this if you really want
to get a true valid quote-unquote gold
standard assessment of body water and
body water compartments
there is no single method
and the researchers are relatively in
consensus that you need to use multiple
different assessments of hydration to
get these different compartments so
you'd probably need to do a
multi-frequency bia or bis along with a
couple other body water assessments and
then you'd be able to actually tell
whether there are these big shifts
i think that in addition to measuring
say
blood pressure changes
in addition to measuring actual glycogen
content rather than just appearance
and i would also like to see some
qualitative
interviews with the or at least
questionnaires with likert scales of the
the participants to ask them how their
pump was
you know because to me that is one of
the main variables that that i i see
influenced by what you do in peak week
is
when it comes time you're about to get
on stage a good pump up can make a
pretty substantial difference in the way
you look and if you can't get one that's
not good
so
i think if you asked all those questions
and then you looked for relationships
between those variables well you could
even bring back circumferences for that
just like absolutely
look at uh look at flexed arm
circumference pre and post pump and like
who's who's getting the bigger pump
absolutely 100 agree and you do that in
conjunction with um
you know the
the the photo uh recommendations i made
previously of using judges who don't
know those people that should get you
through your irb
um and then you can look at
relationships between variables you know
like okay uh we had improvements in the
folks who did x y and z
um and those were related to
these other variables and i think then
we're starting to understand the
mechanisms maybe we see the exact
opposite relationship you know people
who increased their intracellular
extracellular water ratio actually
looked worse
because blood pressure dropped too much
or something i have no idea but i think
it's certainly not
an assumption that we should hold on to
that the underlying assumed
physiological principles of peak week
are in fact doing what we we think
they're doing
because how many times in exercise
science have we thought something works
a certain way and the observation is
correct but the mechanism is wrong
that's a repeated error so i think we we
just don't want to make that same error
now just because
people have been saying it for 40 years
doesn't necessarily mean it's it's the
way things actually working
yeah that that makes sense for sure and
and i had uh
just one more question that i i think i
know the answer to but i'm
always delighted to be surprised so um
the the idea of using bodybuilding
judges to just visually assess how
people are looking based on anonymized
photos
do you know if there's been any research
on the reliability of bodybuilding
judging scores or is that just like is
that a component
of like getting certified to be a
bodybuilding judge because like
ultimately if one were to use that as a
research method the underlying
assumption
would be that that is a valid and
reliable measure and i think it's
inherently valid because ultimately like
if these people are judging the
competitions and these people are
competing in the competitions the scores
from the judges are the scores that
matter so like it's it's inherently a
valid
measure or a yeah it would be a valid
measure but do we know that those
measurements are actually reliable
because i i hear bodybuilders
you know complain about like politics
like ah man i brought a great package
and this other guy beat me but like i i
feel like that's oftentimes sour grapes
but do we is there actual like
quantifiable evidence that bodybuilding
judges
do reliably award scores based on how
people look
great question and i think it is um
so no there's no data on that however
there is a part of the process that is
federation specific which probably
improves reliability so i'm going to
give a shout out to the inbf wnbf
the way they do it if you want to become
a judge is you go through a bit of a
training course and then you do what's
called test judging
so typically at a show you're going to
have
five seven or nine judges and they throw
out
the high and the low score
and then they compile the remaining
judges so you're getting at least
three five or seven
in addition to that there may be two
other people or one other person or
three other people sitting at the
judging table who are there to
unofficially judge the competition as
test judges and i've actually gone
through this process back in the day and
you're supposed to have at least a 80
agreement with the with the final scores
for each division for you to become a
judge and you're supposed to go through
the process of doing this in a local and
then also a bigger show
so i think
if that is the type of procedure that's
followed it'll be great but some other
federations especially in smaller local
areas where they don't have enough
people it's going to be like hey can we
get some competitors and some pros and
some experienced people in the community
to sit on this panel
which is also the source of
the claims of politics issues because
it's
it's great it's a it's like a family and
it's a very small niche community but
everybody knows each other so that means
if yeah any of the judges are a trainer
it's very easy to get claims of of
politics
so yeah
yeah that that makes sense yeah that
sounds like uh it for inbf wnbf that
sounds like a
surprisingly rigorous process so that's
that's really good to hear
yeah i can't say that is the the case
for all federations but just to put it
out there i think that is a good way of
doing things
sweet
uh all right so
looking at the time i don't know that i
have time for q a um it is
6 31 local time and i have uh family
showing up in 15 minutes so i i think it
might be time to play us out
up to you greg if you want to give maybe
one queue
and a even
yeah you know
you know what i i do have one all right
um all right so
yeah this is this is topical for this
episode and this episode only
uh so jordan nathaniel uh in the
stronger by science facebook group asks
uh why is greg not a permanent host yet
and to answer that question i do think
that this episode
shakes up the power structure on the
stronger by science podcast a bit uh
because
eric trexler always refers to himself as
the one and only permanent host of the
podcast and i am the temporary guest
co-host but now
i would say that i myself am the
permanent guest co-host because i have
been on every episode uh but he when he
comes back will be
the temporary
permanent host
um so yeah
still still a guest co-host but i i
would say
that maybe now it's time to flip-flop
who is temporary and who is permanent uh
that is also
now canon within this continuity of the
stronger by science cinematic universe
and again if uh if anyone messes with
that continuity
maybe by the name of eric trexler just
destroy his [ __ ] inbox on instagram
and he will appreciate you for it
well i i personally don't have a dog in
this race so i will i'll let you guys uh
you know debate that next time by the
way that's eric eric at stronger by
science.com
correct he also has social media so if
you don't get an immediate response
within five minutes definitely hit him
up on instagram
facebook
does he
tweet uh
he himself doesn't tweet but he i i see
him liking things on twitter so he he's
on there yeah tweeted him as well just
to make sure you don't wanna you don't
want these types of important issues to
to go under the radar folks
correct
so i think that was easily the most
important question you could have taken
greg so excellent selection
i think it's the only one that i had on
this list that i could answer quickly
fair call fair call so uh what do we
have to place out
yeah so uh we have a media
recommendation uh and this is great that
eric helms is here we we talked about
this before we started recording
i i threw this out as a
potential option for to play us out and
uh
we couldn't do this with eric trexler
because he doesn't watch anything
i think he has seen
maybe fewer than five movies in his
entire life doesn't watch tv uh just not
that kind of guy but uh this is a show
that eric helms and i uh
have you finished season two yet oh yeah
okay we've got two episodes left um but
yeah so
let's see maybe like two weeks ago
my wife and i started watching righteous
gemstones binge the entire first season
almost through the second season all of
the episodes are out already
and uh yeah righteous gemstones it is
such it's such a funny show
um
great characters it's
uh it is so it's starring danny mcbride
and if you've watched some of his stuff
um it tends to be pretty funny but it
can sometimes just be
so over the top that it
um
i don't know like it's it's still fun to
watch an episode at a time but i think
like for binging purposes it can become
like
a little bit grating i think but i i
think righteous gemstones finds a better
tone to make it
both just as funny on an episode by
episode basis but also
much more bingeable uh and i think that
eric and i both agree that that is due
to the tremendous acting chops of john
goodman playing the family's patriarch
eli gemstone delivering an absolutely
phenomenal performance
yeah i can't echo that recommendation
more and i i 100 agree that if it was
just you know mcbride and crew and that
style of of humor um
it wouldn't have the same punch because
i mean
i like greg you mentioned that there are
more absurd things that they have done
this is a pretty absurd show but
you find the absurdity funnier because
it gets brought back with there are a
number of characters in the show who are
are not insane and yeah it reminds you
that they exist in a sane world doing
insane things which makes it funny and i
think john goodman is a
fantastic example of that so yeah yeah i
i echo this recommendation 100
and it is uh it's a show so it's a show
about um
a family that runs a mega church so
as a podcast that supports strong
christian family values um
i would say everything in the righteous
gemstones really helps
put the best foot forward for that
community for our community
so i appreciate that it's
preaching the good word to the masses as
well so not only is it
entertaining it will also
help you get your soul right which you
know you love to see
coming out of the normally godless and
forsaken hollywood entertainment
industry
and again if you're someone who uh maybe
struggles with
satire
or sarcasm
um
and you take any issue with what you see
in that show or you don't feel it aligns
with what greg just said
the email you want to hit is eric
strongerbuyscience.com
absolutely just let us know your
detailed thoughts uh on on on that
specifically and i'm sure it'll get back
to you quickly and if not again social
media just hit them up on all accounts
it's just the most efficient way to
communicate
correct
all right folks well that about does it
for this episode of the stronger by
science podcast
make sure to give us a follow a like and
a subscribe and if you've got any
thoughts comment as well and we'll see
you next time
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode finally please remember that we
are not medical doctors or registered
dietitians so before you make any
changes to your exercise or nutrition
habits be sure to check with a qualified
health care professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you